what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and right now marvel
studios has a lot going on phase four is
well underway and we have plenty of
disney plush shows coming and plenty of
movies coming as well and a lot of
people have been wondering when is it
all going to start to connect now
obviously it all connects in some way
shape or form because everything that we
see is a part of the marvel cinematic
universe however recently with some
shows like moon night there haven't
really been any connections or
references to the mcu with the exception
of a name drop here or there for example
moon knight dropped the name madrapore
but i can confirm that miss marvel is
going to change that there are going to
be a lot of references to the mcu in
that show and a lot of really cool
easter eggs but the question still
remains when is everything going to come
together in a really big way not just
name drops here and there not just
references to other superheroes but when
are the superheroes actually going to
cross over in stories and come together
to have to fight a big bad as of right
now we don't really have a big bad
villain of the mzu however that is about
to change very very soon and yes this
villain is going to be the villain of
secret wars and secret wars might be
coming a lot sooner than we think which
is obviously amazing and exciting news
so let's dive into it and of course if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the recent videos so if you have seen
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness then you have now been
introduced to incursion if you haven't
or you don't quite understand it don't
worry i'll explain it now the simplified
version of this is that two universes
collide into each other causing the
destruction of one or both of the
universes incursions can happen for
several different reasons but one of the
reasons that the illuminati gives is
that simply one person traveling into
another universe that is not theirs can
cause an incursion in fact the ultimate
doctor strange earth 838's doctor
strange caused an incursion simply by
going into another universe now this is
going to play a huge part of secret wars
in the mcu but it is not the start of
secret wars in the mcu we'll talk about
that in a second but first what you need
to know about the secret wars comic
storyline is that incursion plays a
really big role in the story two
universes collide into one and it looks
like this is very clearly being set up
in the mcu in fact in the post-credits
scene for multiverse of madness spoiler
alert we are introduced to clea and she
says that doctor strange caused an
incursion already so the events of
secret wars are already well underway
but they actually started in loki and
this is very important to know because a
lot of people think that just because
god emperor doom and the beyonder and
some other villains were the main
villains of the comic storyline secret
wars battle world that means that
they're going to have to be the villains
in the mcu secret war story as well
which is incorrect marvel studios
doesn't ever truly stick page by page to
the comics they take inspiration from
the stories and that's about it which is
really good because if they didn't do
that then we would know anything and
everything that was going to happen in
all the movies but it's looking like the
beyonder or god emperor doom are not
going to be the villain of secret wars
but it's going to be the person who has
been set up to be the villain from the
very beginning in loki and that person
is king the conqueror if we go back to
loki in the final episode we can already
see that a secret wars battle has
already happened we've already seen a
multiversal war now this war was between
kang's variants and eventually the king
that we met at the end of loki who
technically wasn't king it was he who
remains he came out on top and he
created the tva and he created the
sacred timeline and he kept everything
in check however when loki and sylvie
got to him he made it very clear that if
they did not take his place but they
killed him instead essentially his
variants would be released and a new
multiversal war would come now miss
minutes told us that the original
multiversal war almost ended in the
destruction of the entire multiverse and
this was obviously now that we know this
due to incursion now this would be a
little bit of a different incursion this
would be one can going to another
universe and trying to rule it or
completely get rid of it entirely
because that was the actual goal of all
of these kings they wanted to control
the entire multiverse not just their
universe but this new multiversal war
this new secret wars is not just going
to be between the kang variants because
now people are becoming very well aware
of the multiverse and incursions and
best believe that our heroes and heroes
of other universes are going to want to
band together to stop a multiversal war
from happening and this is where the
main villain of secret wars comes in the
main villain is kang we've actually
known this for a very long time now
people tend to forget this because we
haven't seen much connection to loki or
really anything else since the start of
phase 4. but don't worry it's about to
go down pretty soon and i have a feeling
when we get to ant-man and the wasp
quantum mania it's really gonna hit the
fan because that is when the actual king
is going to be introduced not a he who
remains variant of king but the actual
kang and do you remember what he who
remains said in loki oh guess what
if you think i'm
evil
well this way
till you meet my
variants
his variants are a lot more evil than
him in fact he doesn't even consider
himself evil he considers himself the
person who brought peace to the
multiverse this is not the same king
that we are going to be meeting the one
that we're going to meet in ant-man 3 is
going to be the true villain and from
what i've heard there are actually going
to be a few different variants of king
the cockerer who are going to be the
main villains so our heroes the avengers
doctor strange all of these other ones
that haven't really come together yet
they're not just going to have to deal
with one king but they're going to have
to deal with multiple kangs and the
kangs will probably fight each other as
well kind of going by the original story
of the original multiversal war where
the kangs tried to dominate the
multiverse we can assume that the same
thing will probably happen here a bunch
of different kings will show up trying
to take over the universe so our heroes
are going to run into multiple variants
of king all of which are trying to take
over the universe but i would like to
think that the main villain of this
secret war storyline that is going to
happen in the mcu well that's already
happening in the mcu is going to be
actually our universe's version of kang
the conqueror nathaniel richards now
nathaniel richards technically should
not be born yet he is born way into the
future but in the future he comes across
a time traveling machine and manages to
go back in time all the way back to
ancient egyptian times and he becomes
the pharaoh rama tut in fact in moon
night we got actual easter eggs for kang
the conqueror as ramatu and these were
confirmed to be actual easter eggs so
kang is here he's in our universe but
he's most likely right now in the
quantum realm which is why ant-man and
the wasp quantum mania is going to be
the real film to bring kang into the mcu
now this is all really really exciting
and if you think it is exciting well
guess what it's actually going to get
even more exciting because i believe
that while all of this is happening
they're actually going to bring cosmic
entities into the picture the reason i
think this is because we have now seen
the living tribunal pop up in three
different instances the first one isn't
exactly him but it is a statue of his
three heads that we saw in loki the
second time we saw him was just recently
in doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness where doctor strange and america
chavez are going through a bunch of
different multiverses we see the living
tribunals heads we actually see multiple
heads actually looking like they're kind
of watching what doctor strange and
america chavez are doing and then in the
trailer for thor love and thunder we can
see a statue of a golden living tribunal
plus not to mention in the first doctor
strange film mordo has the staff of the
living tribunal the living tribunal's
job is to protect the multiverse so if
kangs are going to be released and they
are threatening another multiversal war
i believe that the living tribunal and
possibly other cosmic entities because
in the thor love and thunder trailer we
saw a few cosmic entities i believe
they'll get involved for the protection
of the multiverse and like i just stated
i believe that the living tribunal was
actually watching what doctor strange
and america chavez were doing monitoring
them to see if they would actually cause
the destruction of the entire multiverse
now they did a lot they did bring the
scarlet witch into the earth 838
universe in which she did kill the
entire illuminati so you think that
would have been enough for the living
tribunal to step in but i guess since it
didn't result in the destruction of the
universe entirely it wasn't really
called for yet but that makes me really
curious to see what actually is called
for for him to step in what has to
happen for the living tribunal and other
cosmic entities to interfere with
humanity that i believe is coming and
i'm really really excited to see it and
recently a lot of people have been
talking online several insiders have
been stating that secret wars should be
coming a lot sooner than everybody
thinks a lot of people think that
everything needs to build up again it's
going to take another 10 years for the
next avengers in-game level event to
happen again but according to some it's
probably going to be coming in 2026 and
according to some rumors online it was
even supposed to come in 2024 but
unfortunately the pandemic pushed it
back but this is great news if we only
have to wait four more years till
another avengers end game that's really
not bad and definitely is a lot closer
than i expected especially since we
don't even really have an avengers team
right now but we have plenty of time for
heroes to come together to form an
avengers team so i'm not worried about
it at all but i am really really excited
so let me know what you think about all
of this in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
future videos for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof